an Iraqi man who sparked outrage by
staging Quran burning protest in Sweden
in 20223 has been shot dead according to
Swedish
authorities Islam net is raising funds
to establish a Masjid and Community
Center in Norway and they urgently need
your support this donation will be a for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear
friends the Quran
has been shot dead okay so here is the
one of the news we're going to read in
we're going to come to some facts
because I like the selective outrage
media outlet and a lot of people do and
let me honest be honest with you Muslims
and we've come to the point where we
don't really care man we don't care
about your opinions we don't care about
what you think about Islam we just do
not care Islam is the fastest going
religion alhamdulillah nothing stopping
it people have waken up to the reality
of Islam being the truth people are Le
in atheism they're turning to Islam
millions of PE Christians are turning to
Islam alhamdulillah Islam is growing
it's the truth it works it's pragmatic
so alhamdulillah so these kind of
stories I'm the reason I'm covering not
to say oh look I just want to tell you
guys I don't care what you guys think
blame Isam don't blame I don't care but
one thing I want to make clear is that
we do not condone anything like this I
just want to make a disclaimer before
anyone jumps onto it you know uh these
kind of things at the end of the day
yeah um there is capital punishment in
Islam for people who desecrate
scriptures um however that's done with
an Amir a ruler and it's done with
courts it doesn't work of vigilantism
where you go out and Hunt people down
there's a capital punishment for anyone
that causes corruption in Islamic land
but no nowhere in Islam does it say that
one takes m in his own own hands and
does things like that so I make that
disclaimer nobody's Condon violence here
we actually condemning it in Nut Show
now let's come to this uh situation here
now u a man who staged Quran burning
protest in Sweden Sweden shot dead
authori say so here we go now just
quickly read on this and I'm going to
make some very important points here
okay Salman Mika um an Iraqi man who
sparked outrage by staging Quran burning
protest in Sweden in 20223 has been shot
dead according to Swedish authorities a
spokesperson for Sweden prosecutors
Prosecutors office confirmed CNN that
Mika was shot dead in the capital city
Stockholm on Wednesday Stockholm police
told CNN that five people had been
arrested on Wednesday night on suspicion
of murder Mika Mika was on Thursday said
set to be headed handed a verdict in a
trial where he was accused of incitement
to ra hatred Goran lunda a lawyer for
Stockholm's District Court told CNN
sentencing has now been postponed in
2023 Moma Tau CNN that he had come to
Sweden from Iraq in 2018 so just to get
a Asylum SE can you imagine um selling
your religion for the dun and losing the
dun Hereafter just imagine the horrors
now imagine him his soul and the angel
of death comes and says come out to the
wrath of your lord and from this moment
to Eternity you are going to be in the
Hellfire he said he had carried that
demonstration because he believed the
Quran should be banned in the world
because of the danger it causes
democracy ethnics human values human
rights and woman's rights it just
doesn't work in this time and age oh my
gosh yes look who's look who's look
who's talking yeah so Swedish
authorities had first attempt to prevent
Mica from staging protest by denying him
a police permit to demonstrate the
decision was later overturned by
Stockholm's court of appeals citing
freedom of speech guys freedom of speech
the things the Western values like the
French flag you dare to insult like
macron you know you dare to insult him
the president the flag whatever it is no
no no no no no freedom of speech there
but the Quran freedom of speech you
bloody Hypocrites you bloody hypocrit
the whole world can see the hypocrisy
you guys live on an account on X pting
to Monica regularly posted updates on
his 2025 trial to more than 230,000
followers the account has regularly
posted anti-islam sentiments this month
the account was asking for donation to
go towards the lawyer who was reportedly
helping Monica to get asylum in the
United States oh just for that Asylum a
prosecutor will now be in charge of
investigating the murder the stockhom
police said security services will be
involved in this investigation by the
way apparently if I'm not mistaken what
I was told is that um this happened when
he was streaming or something like that
and like I said before and I want to
give you guys an example this is not
exclusive to Islam if this was a Muslim
who done it by the way yeah it's not
exclusive to Islam
any religion like that movie I forgot
the movie um where he goes to a
neighborhood I forgot the I don't really
watch movies yeah he went to a black
neighborhood and he was like something u
n i g g if you go to a specific
neighborhood and be racist if I go to
the Bible Belt to Texas or whatever yes
okay where is Hill are Mississippi and I
burn the Bible do you really think the
Christians are not going to attempt to
kill me like are you that if I
go to a nationalist Hindu hindutva area
and I burn their bakat Gita or whatever
it is their scripture do you not think
there's going to be people like there's
going to attempt to try to kill me you
play stupid games and you pay you play
stupid games you win stupid prices it's
as simple as as that there are Muslims
out there who also again they do silly
things like that so the point is this is
not exclusive to Islam wherever you go
if I go to a specifically Russia and
insult the Russians and provoke them and
insult them they are bound to attack me
wherever you go this is basic human
psychology is this right no but we don't
live in Disneyland that's the reality so
all I want to say is this guys this
hypocrisy this double standards is clear
freedom of speech when you burn the
Quran can we burn the Torah can we burn
the Jewish scripture oh no we can't can
we oh no we can't can we what happened
to freedom of speech you bloody
hypocrite morons so all I want to say is
we do not condone what anyone doing
going out there and taking this is not
from Islam yes for someone to go and
take their matters into their own hands
but anyways on a li note guys till next
time and the enemies of Islam watching
this die out of Rage bite your hands out
of Rage trying to blame Islam for this
so guys till next
time better care too